Amnesty International issued a damning
report on the deaths of 49 people during
anti-government protests in Peru the
investigation concluded that the killing
of demonstrators was a result of
coordinated State response we have
documented the killing of 20 people
and those killings were in our
Opie buried and intentional that means
that these individuals were the victims
of extrajudicial executions
the Rights group says authorities did
nothing to stop the excessive and lethal
use of force against defenseless and
unarmed protesters especially in the
Andean region where most people died the
highest level of authority was involved
either
by giving an order
to shoot
or
by failing to prevent the shooting
in both scenarios the responsibilities
of the security and civil apparatus is
engaged
lost his brother who was helping injured
protesters in puno where 17 people were
killed in one afternoon
we were accused of being vandals
terrorists maybe because the color of
our skin but we are human beings
and her government defended the actions
of the security forces said each case
has to be investigated Peru's attorney
general has summoned president boluarte
and Senior Army and police officers to
testify on the killings at the end of
the month but victims lawyers say it's
not guaranteed they'll be allowed in the
session and are demanding the right to
be heard
the Amnesty International report says
reparations should be given to families
of victims and the injured Miguel Salas
survived a tear gas canister hit that
destroyed part of his call of course I
lose my memory I can't work I need to
know who did this to me I didn't deserve
this
has blamed former president Pedro
Castillo jailed before the violent
protests rocked the country for the
deaths she didn't say why but what's
certain is her government now has a lot
of explaining to do Mariana Sanchez Lima